Three Students Were Asked About The
Probability Of Passing In The Mathematics
Paper Let's Understand The
Responses The First Student Was Very Sad And Said That
The Probability Of His Passing
Was Low The Second One Was Really Happy Because He
Felt That The Probability Of His
Passing Is Very  High The third kid was a little
confused he says that his probability
of passing is somewhere in between so the
probability just tells you how like it is for this event to happen if
the event is passing the
exam
in the first case the like of passing is  Not
very like in the second case The like method of
passing is very like and the like of
passing is summer in between but none of them are sharing they are just
telling us what they feel and
what is the most like outcome
[Music]
probability